Felix this declaration does not come as
a surprise president Felix chess got 12
million votes his closest competitor Mo
katumbi Hard 3 million opposition
presidential candidates say the election
was
rigged certain candidat some candidates
used violence vandalism and Corruption
they intimidated our employees during
voting the aim was to rig the election
in their
favor opposition leaders say they will
reject that outcome and they will not
even go to court because they believe
the Constitutional court is compromised
so they will take their fight to the
streets some election observers have
raised concerns about how the poll was
conducted delays technical itches and
other irregularities characterized the
voting process M Kad and M Toto the
Electoral commission president and his
team must be arrested they've thrown the
country into disarray that is why we're
telling our supporters to resist the
president has asked conges to put aside
their differences and get down to
business I would like to reassure you
that this second mandate that you have
granted me will be dedicated to more
action to achieve commitments I've made
to transform Congress some analysts say
the president's work is cut out for him
he needs to deal with sec
problems in the East tame inflation and
Corruption and heal a deeply divided
nation Katherine so Al jaaz
Kinshasa make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jaaz